[Music]
all right what's up everybody today we
are going to do the
what do we call this spicy ramen channel
spicy ramen challenge and we have the
this one there's so many brands that do
this i'm like we're doing
this one is this is this the brand to
use so this is two times spicy we're
gonna be eating this while we're reading
some children's books these are your old
uh spanish books huh yeah that mommy
bought for you i remember this one
remember that i remember that you don't
remember this one i've been trying to
learn spanish isaac i think you're
kind of always wanting to learn spanish
but this is hard huh yeah having me
around the house we never actually end
up
speaking in spanish we actually tried
doing this challenge a while back but we
actually did it wrong
we didn't realize we're not supposed to
serve this with this soup we're not
supposed to serve this with the water
that looks deadly it does so we're gonna
make this now we're gonna keep it super
spicy for ourselves
and we're gonna see if we can read some
spanish while we're at it
so in order to do it right we are going
to just cook the noodles
and not put all the seasoning packets in
because that's what we did wrong last
time
me and my cousin would get ramen out of
the pantry
and then we'll just eat it i knew a lot
of kids that did that too
they would just put the seasoning packet
on the dry noodle and just eat it like a
chip oh no we'll just eat it by itself
we want it we'll just eat the ramen
really that's good to you and today
we're actually having a cookout
we got some black beans over here at the
boiling i got the smoker out there going
with some chickens on there
and some rice to go with the beans and
probably going to make some lomo saltado
in a little bit as well i think it's
ready to go
[Music]
stop it stop it i should i should use
this
i don't know why those things yeah i'm
trying to be too asian about it
americans use this
we're going to mesh them around with
them sticks
all right here we go three two one all
right so now we have
our bowl of not spicy ramen
packet says to put eight spoonfuls of
water but we're not gonna do that
we're gonna torture ourselves can you do
this can you handle this eating yeah
on a regular level of spice right just
typical hot cheeto spices
how do you like that do you like spicy
foods yeah yeah they're
enjoyable do you enjoy torturing
yourself with
spicy foods not really such as what
we're about to do right now
no it says you always taught me ideas
are dangerous i know it looks like blood
look at this should i rub my knife
[Music]
actually now i kind of do want to put
water but it's too far
you're committed at least you gotta stay
committed it smells
like torture so i'm not a big spice
person either it's not even so much my
palette for spice
powder spice is all right that's my
digestion system that
cannot handle any sort of spice anymore
you should put your finger on the side
just
dab it and put it on your mouth you know
how they say blood brothers
we're gonna be spiced father and son
all right here we go cheers
we have our meal and we have our book
and we have our spanish book
my good friend aka is holding the camera
for us because we're having a cookout
this is
so backstory is we're having a cookout
ak's like hey
let's do something while we're there and
so i'm like all right what do you want
to do and he's like well i got these two
packets of ramen spicy ramen
why don't you guys eat that and i
thought he was gonna join us but instead
now he's holding the camera
filming nuts basically i did it by
myself i couldn't do it
i failed and uh i want to see someone
else fell so here we go
hit hit thumbs up if you want to see ak
fail too we got 5 000 units
5 000 likes gotcha
that's doable good luck isaac i need a
little bit i love you dude
all right uh i'm not ready yet no this
is even a word
me that's like music talk three
[Music]
yes one two three is uno dos thres
oh my goodness there's a noodle stuck to
my braces and it's burning
hands are models vrps arms or brussels
viennese or legs
[Laughter]
these pictures look nice though we did
not set ourselves up for success
there's no water on this table and gotta
train through in this train
hurry uh
it's trying to tremble tremble tremble
that's the word
cheater cheater
we sauced together i'll give you one
all right your turn there you go
children last place please
don't rate me don't know what i'm saying
you try some of this and see if you like
it you did not get this far did you
agree i did not get that far
no it hurts and i had water in mine are
you done isaac
nope tapping out maybe so i got some of
the book
ding dong
libros i am
that's not what i want to hear okay that
is not what i want to hear
i'm going one more bite i'm gonna still
regret it you're gonna matter if like 30
minutes
that toilet over there it's not gonna
work like it's not gonna like me
you're crying got a spicy chicken on the
grill right now
spicy chicken is not gonna be edible
after this hmm so good
hey gay where's my partner where's my
partner at
we ride together we die together right
hey isaac
i feel like i'm dying alone here
face of a champion face of a winner
there's not no one to quit
i should have quit does not feel good to
be a champion yeah how you feeling
terrible i don't like you anymore get
out of my house no i feel my face
it's on fire right now oh milk top me
off
help me out tommy let's kick it in let's
cook it in
hurry hurry hurry but then
it comes right back it's like one of
those party candles
so in this house we have this rule we
don't waste food we never throw anything
out we're wait where we're
fish that is food we're in this house
what do we do about that
we throw it out well i mean you couldn't
eat it no
[Music]
moment you think it's gone
it stays in between the teeth that's
what it is don't do this guys at home
click like subscribe
[Music]
you